there's a new cronyism allegation
against the health secretary
matt hancock it concerns some shares
he's been given in a family firm which
has been doing business with the
national health service it is being
claimed he hasn't properly declared it
the government insists he has though now
mr hancock was given some shares in a
company called
topwood it's owned by his sister
and also other family members now he
declared the shares in the earlier this
week in the register of members interest
um and at the time it was thought the
company had just been doing business
with the nhs in wales
now it's emerged according to the health
service journal
that the company's been doing business
with the national health service in
england uh for which of course mr
hancock is responsible
as health secretary though he isn't
responsible for the nhs in wales
uh it is being claimed that he
didn't state in ministerial declarations
that his sister
and other family members owned the firm
uh jonathan
ashworth the shadow health secretary has
tweeted
shocking but sadly i suspect no one is
surprised anymore
at the cronyism at the heart of this
government
well a spokesman for the the health
secretary said that
he's acted entirely properly all
declarations of interest have been made
in accordance with the mineral
ministerial code ministers have no
involvement in the awarding of these
contracts
no conflict of interest arises uh it's
being
said by the department that he wasn't
involved
um he checked with the permanent
secretary
whether there are any conflicts of
interest and the department is saying
these shareholdings are only known about
because he's followed the transparency
rules in the full and correct way
john craig updating us there from
westminster thank you